alles wird teuer die Energie kostet viel
im Supermarkt ist alles teurer geworden
und genau zu diesem Zeitpunkt gibt man
eine ganz große Menge Geld aus 777
Millionen von schicken Anbau von
Kanzleramt und das sagt Bela Anna könnte
ein bisschen zu viel sein
77 Millionen offiziell nach jetzigem
Stand soll das neue Kanzleramt der Anbau
des Kanzleramt ist kümmern wir sollen
alle den Gürtel länger schneiden wir
sollen sparen wir müssen sparen das ist
ja die Botschaft die Regierung heute
setzt auch bei seiner Rede heute
kämpferische Rede im Bundestag Olaf
Scholz nach dem Motto wir haben viel
geschafft aber parallel dazu gibt es
diese Pläne 77 Millionen nach jetzigen
bedeuten dass die jetzigen zahlen soll
dieses neue Kanzleramt bauen Kosten
schräg gegenüber dem Reichstag das
berichtet heute die FAZ schon jetzt muss
man sich vorstellen gibt es im
Kanzleramt 13 Wintergärten weitere 9
sollen in zu kommen dazu Dachgärten
Kitas eine neue Wohnung für den
Bundeskanzler oder die Bundes wer weiß
es denn nach dem Motto Ausflüge
Westflügel oder doch zu Hause wo schlafe
ich heute Nacht
schon jetzt ist das Kanzleramt dreimal
so groß wie der elise-palast in Paris
und acht Mal so groß wie das Weiße Haus
aber es soll halt noch viel viel größer
werden keine Dekadenz wie es heute im
Bundestag heißt sondern angeblich
Notwendigkeit weil einige der
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter über
verschiedene Büros in Berlin verteilt
sind aber wir haben hier alle aus Corona
gelernt das ist unmodern ist sich in
einem äh quasiort fest zu Ketten und
viele eigentlich auch zu Hause arbeiten
wollen also ein bisschen mehr Modernität
Flexibilität kann man auch im
Bundeskanzleramt walten lassen gerade
wenn wir aufgefordert werden den Gürtel
enger zu schneiden und zu sparen und die
Ausrede das haben die Vorgängerregierung
entschieden Angela Merkel sei sozusagen
dafür verantwortlich ist natürlich
wirklich billig denn ein Kanzler kann
sowas immer stoppen gerade wenn noch
kein Spatenstich Erfolg ist deswegen
wecken diesen Platzbau und hin zu etwas
mehr Bescheidenheit und Flexibilität der
Steuerzahler bezahlen
Bescheidenheit von uns allen auch
derzeit in diesen Zeiten verlangt acht
Mal größer als das Weiße Haus ich finde
das ist so eine Zahl die bleibt jetzt
schon ganz schön im Kopf überschätzt
Deutschland da seine weltpolitische
Bedeutung nicht die weltpolitische
sondern die eigene weil was ich mich ja
gefragt habe ist was um Himmels willen
muss plötzlich im Kanzleramt so viel
mehr getan werden dass wir diesen Anbau
und auch diese diese personalexplosion
haben das ist eigentlich das was mich
viel mehr interessiert nämlich welche
Kompetenzen hier offensichtlich im
Kanzleramt zusammengezogen werden und wo
werden die eigentlich abgezogen also man
bläht hier sozusagen eigentlich einen
Regierungssitz auf äh das ist nicht nur
eine Geldfrage sondern ist es ja auch
eine inhaltliche Sache dass man sagt was
was ist das hier für also sowas kann ich
früher nur ich bin in Rumänien geboren
ne da hat man auch solche Paläste
hingebaut irgendwie
aber das ist ja tatsächlich sozusagen
eine aufblähen und ein Kompetenzen an
sich reißen dass man sagt hier alles
unter einem Dach wofür haben wir
eigentlich noch Ministerien die die in
irgendeiner Form arbeiten aber ich habe
heute wunderbar gehört irgendwie dass es
jetzt auch ein Hubschrauber es soll auch
ein Hubschrauberlandeplatz auf Stellen
geben irgendwie beim Bundeskanzleramt
weil der nämlich auf der gleichen Wiese
gebaut wird wo eigentlich die Kita ist
und jetzt haben sie das Problem jetzt
muss man für fast 30 Millionen
aufstellen diesen Flugplatz für da wo
der Helikopter für den Kanzler
sicherlich
weil wenn der auf dem Rasen landen würde
dann würde er ja die Kinder die Kinder
wegnehmen also muss quasi der
Hubschrauberlandeplatz aufstellen in die
Höhe gestellt werden allein das kostet
30 Millionen und da sieht man einfach
was für ein aber witzig äh hier ist ich
möchte wirklich nichts mehr über Strom
sparen oder was sonst was hören ja wenn
wir so Geld zum Fenster rausschmeißen
und dieses Geld offensichtlich da ist
haben wir nicht dann Problem das zu
wenig Geld da ist sondern nur das ist in
die falschen kann wir machen noch ein
bisschen mehr Schulden das ist ja das
Problem das Geld ist ja nicht mehr da
der Stadt ist ja schon hoch verschuldet
und es werden noch mehr Schulden gemacht
und noch mehr Schulden gemacht und wer
zahlt am Ende der Steuerzahler aber ich
danke Ihnen erkenne jetzt jetzt habe ich
endlich begriffen was das Wort
Helikopter Eltern bedeutet
[Gelächter]
und die Eltern im Prenzlauer Berg die
Helikopter Eltern die werden dann
natürlich auch dankbar aber man muss
schon die Frage stellen einmal hat die
Politik da ein bisschen die Bodenhaftung
verloren
ja mit Sicherheit also es ist ja nicht
nur das Bundeskanzleramt was aufgebaut
wird also seit antritt dieser Koalition
sind 10.000
365 oder 63 möchte ich jetzt nicht
streiten mich um 23 Uhr stellen dazu
gekommen
das Wirtschaftsministerium wird umgebaut
ähm das Außenministerium wird auch
umgebaut ich verstehe das man will auch
feministische Außenpolitik machen
aber ob man deswegen
1236 mehr Beamte braucht ist fraglich
fragwürdig also man sieht einen Ausbau
von Personal und ich habe vor einem
Monat mit einem ehemaligen
Ministerpräsidenten geredet der sagte zu
mir also es ist ja alles schon
vorgekommen in der Bundesrepublik aber
er hat noch nie ein so ein solchen
Ausbau von Staat erlebt wie wir das
jetzt in der Ampel erleben wie kann es
sein viele andere lange
ist leider in der Politik hat man hat
den Eindruck der wird irgendwie so eine
kleine Parallelwelt wie eine Bubble
geschaffen wie hast du das wahrgenommen
wird den Politikern auch nur das gesagt
was sie hören wollen also sind sie im
Prinzip immer weiter abgehoben haben sie
überhaupt noch Bodenhaftung ja das haben
sie schon nur in der Politik gilt und es
gilt bis heute so je mehr man hat desto
mehr ist man tatsächlich auch und die
mehr man hat desto mehr Gewicht bringt
man deswegen politische Macht hat ich
habe damals im Bundesamt tatsächlich war
der Glaube der einzige und der
vielleicht dümmste in diesem
Zusammenhang der wirklich eine Abteilung
abgegeben hat weil wir eine Abteilung
eine Auslandsabteilung hatten und der
ich gesehen habe dass die Doppelarbeit
macht mit dem Beamten die im ausserdem
Amt waren habe ich gesagt okay das
können wir ändern wir können hier auch
den Steuerzahler entlasten und das
können wir auch mit weniger
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern machen
habt ihr dann darüber gegeben dort und
das war natürlich im Sinne des Hauses
habe ich da quasi ähm
macht abgegeben oder gleich nicht der
Fall nicht nur sie müssen sich erstmal
gegen gegen solche Sachen wehren weil
derjenige der mehr Mitarbeiterin mehr
hat der ist der wichtigere und sowas ne
auch völlig egal ob die jetzt effizient
und sinnvoll handeln oder nicht und
deswegen ist ein Kanzleramt oder noch
mehr Leute sind im Zweifel wichtiger und
nach außen macht voller das geht für
andere Ministerien genauso noch eine
Abteilung mehr noch eine unter Abteilung
mehr noch ein Plan Planstellen geht in
der Wissenschaft genauso ja auch ich
frage mich immer diese ganzen
zusätzlichen Mittel die für
Wissenschaften
wissenschaftsmittel bewilligt werden die
gehen ja selten in forschen meistens in
irgendwelche Stellen wo sie dann
versickern und so haben wir glaube ich
dann grundsätzliches Problem wo sie
sagen wir müssen uns auf die auf die
effiziente Verwendung von Mitteln gerade
von Steuermitteln konzentrieren und
nicht gucken dass wir unser Apparate
immer weiter aufblähen lustig also
eigentlich nicht lustig in den
Zusammenhang aber das ist wirklich noch
so funktioniert mein Auto mein
Ministerium meine Mitarbeiter und da
erzählt deine Größe hier einmal hinlegen
vor allen Dingen das schlimme ist ja die
machen sich ja selber die können sich ja
bedienen also jeder Unternehmer müsste
dafür irgendwo das Geld erwirtschaften
und die Politik die greift ins
steuersättel oder in irgendwelche Töpfe
rein und wenn da nichts drin ist im
Zweifel wird halt Geld gedruckt und es
wird einfach nur gemacht und keiner wird
zur Rechenschaft gezogen und und was
eben schon gesagt wurde und das gerade
in Zeiten wo vom Bürger immer mehr
Verzicht eingefordert wird ich habe
zuletzt auch in einem Podcast gesagt ist
die Empathie der der Politik gegenüber
der Bevölkerung die ist völlig verloren
gegangen
sie mir auch gefordert den Bau zu
stoppen kann das passieren ist es
überhaupt realistisch interessiert es
jemanden dass sie hier reden dass wir
sagen das ist so aufgeht es kostet so
viel man braucht es auch nicht mehr
Helikopter Platz auf Stelzen an der Kita
alles quatscht
glaube ich schon das ist eine
öffentliche Debatte jetzt sie wird
politisiert und alles was politisiert
wird
kommt ihr in die Öffentlichkeit und hat
ja schon Wirkung und wenn viele Menschen
das sagen dann kann es schon sein nur im
Moment macht die sich die
Bundesregierung das sehr sehr einfach
indem sie gesagt ja wir haben sie nicht
entschieden das war Angela Merkel aber
natürlich hätten sie gemacht das zu
stoppen ist auch das stimmt ja nicht
ganz tschuldigung aber der jetzige
Kanzler war vorher der Vizekanzler also
er kann ja nicht sagen ich habe mit der
Regierung Merkel nichts zu tun sondern
das ist ja in einer großen Koalition
gemeinsam beschlossen worden das
Kanzleramt das heißt die Distanzierung
jetzt also einerseits kann man der Ampel
das gar nicht in die Schuhe schieben
weil sie hatte übernommen einen
Bauprojekt gleichzeitig also der einzige
der sozusagen vorher und nachher dabei
war war eigentlich der Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz und deswegen wird er sich
auch deswegen nicht distanzieren weil
dann müsste er ja erklären warum er
vorher dafür war und jetzt dagegen ist
und warum sollte man daran auch
Interesse haben also hier die größte
zählt ist mehr und so besser gesagt
sozusagen ach nee lieber nicht lass mal
sparen alle waren mit dabei es ist ganz
schwer sich jetzt zu distanzieren und
das erklärt vielleicht auch irgendwie
warum so wenig Widerstand gibt weil
natürlich auch vorher in einer großen
Koalition das alles beschlossen ist
jetzt sind Leute in der Regierung die
vorher beteiligt waren ja also und so
ein Bauprojekt zu stoppen ich glaube
selbst wenn man es wollte wäre es glaube
ich also wäre immer noch ziemlich viel
Geld das ausgegeben wird weil sie können
natürlich nicht genau sie haben ja
Vertragsstrafen und alles das heißt das
heißt da sind ja schon Gelder bewilligt
da sind Verträge mit mit Bauunternehmen
und alles das heißt selbst wenn man das
Projekt ablehnt ist geht wahrscheinlich
die Hälfte des Geld ist auf jeden Fall
drauf also wir haben ja nicht nur das
größte Bundeskanzleramt aller Zeiten wir
haben auch den größten Bundestag aller
Zeiten und vielleicht gibt es da ja auch
einen inneren Zusammenhang das heißt ich
denke schon dass es schwer fallen mag
Politikern zu sagen wir müssen
reduzieren wir müssen bei uns auch
anfangen vielleicht bräuchten wir auch
eine Demokratie Tiere Form darüber kann
man ja nachdenken aber auf alle Fälle
muss das geschehen und müsste auch
Politik aufpassen dass sie nicht um mal
ein Wort zu gebrauchen was ich nicht
gern sage weil es so abgegriffen ist und
nicht aus der Zeit zu